do people understand what happens to you
after you win one of these awards you go
through like a little grinder huh yeah I
mean I think your your Adrenaline's go
it's really a wild ride yeah I thought
it was beautiful that you talked about
Alexis and that that was a moment that
everybody needed to hear what did it
mean to you what was going through your
mind when you when you walked up there
that expect that at all but the truth is
it's a wonderful moment but I've been
working back-to-back for a long time and
of course I've been sad about Alexis the
whole time but yeah
we've been talking a lot lately I really
really feel like I'm just starting to
mourn her so I would be disingenuous if
I was up there and that wasn't a part of
me that's such an important part of me
right now and I think we are always
running away from grief and we're not
processing or retaining like we're cool
we're pretending like we're fine and I
don't really feel completely fine right
now as wonderful as everything is I also
feel really sad but that's important to
acknowledge that yeah that's okay
this lady in that that moving this
golden lady yes we talked about this on
the carpet you played two women who were
really messed up how do you get those
women out of your system it was kind of
heavy and it kind of took a while I mean
totally really hung on in a way where
she was she was so depressed and I think
depression can kind of hang on for a
while and with DD she was just heavy it
was a a very heavy story so just
emotionally I mean how diluted she was
and what she was willing to do for her
own needs yeah was was really heavy so I
just feel like I've only recently
actually been kind of shook it all off
shook on it all right your family how I
mean I know that they just see you as oh
you're just mom you just want it's no
big deal but they've got to be excited I
think they're they're certainly proud of
me and happy for me to be celebrated but
I don't think they
you know I'm mom isn't it weird though
that like here you are this emmy-winning
starting you go home and you're like
just oh mom I love that do you yeah I
love when you know when I go and my kids
complaining and my kid wants chicken
soup and takes me for granted sometimes
I don't love it so much but in general
it's like yeah I'm your mom you get to
do that you get to be kind of snarky
sometimes you get to take me for granted
a little bit because I'm your mom I'm
not something outside of you you know
mm-hmm
do people process that how crazy the
whole premise of the act is but it
happens all the time it's really bizarre
it's so strange I mean and you know the
really sad thing that we don't talk
about a lot is one in ten kids die for
this it is a deadly thing it's a very
dangerous thing and I can't tell you how
many people have come up to me since we
made this who said my neighbors like
that my niece is like that my mom was
like that I met several people and even
online kids who are taken away from
their mom who are like that it's such a
wound such an incredible wound to be
injured by your parent in that way what
is this lady go she goes in my office
yeah she is going on my office on a
shelf with her friends you know really
badass right I'd put her on the hood
that's what I was gonna say why don't
anybody do that what's she's so happy
she'd dent your hood I'll tell you that
right now you're gonna have a car made
of solid steel what they have an I'm
waiting for somebody to strap one of
these their hood and just drive it -
what - someone might steal it I'd have
to take it off every day that's actually
magnetized or something
Patricia drive it to work and then take
it off but drive it there going down can
you imagine going through the street
look how beautiful it is I mean it's
perfect
um I am here for you if you will drive
with that thing on your hood okay I'll
call you and I'll give you a ride around
the block well why hang out we'll go you
know to the drive-in movie dinner rockin
your Emmy
thank you and congratulations
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]